سيف العدل زعيم تنظيم القاعده الجديد مقيم
في ايران كما تؤكد كل من واشنطن والامم
المتحده محقق سابق في مكافحه الارهاب
بمكتب التحقيقات الفيدراليه الامريكي قال
ان سيف العدل يقيم في ايران منذ 2002 او
2003 حيث وضع في البدايه رهن الاقامه
الجبريه لكنه اصبح حرا فيما بعد بما يكفي
للقيام برحلات الى باكستان ووفق وكاله
الانباء الفرنسيه كتب المحقق في مقال نشر
قبل سنتين ان سيف العدل احد اكثر
المقاتلين المحترفين خبره في تنظيم
القاعده وجسده يحمل ندوب المعركه المعلومه
حول الرجل قليله اسمه الاصلي محمد صلاح
الدين زيدان يبلغ من العمر 62 عاما كان
مسؤولا عن تامين اسامه بن لادن ودرب بعض
المتورطين في هجمات الحادي عشر من سبتمبر
تولى قياده الجناح العسكري لتنظيم القاعده
واقام معسكرات تدريب في السودان وباكستان
وافغانستان ليست له صور تقريبا باستثناء
ثلاث صور احداها بالابيض والاسود من ابرز
صفاته قدرته على التخطيط في الظل بعنايه
لعمليه دمويه
ومساعدته في تحويل القاعده الى اكثر
الجماعات المسلحه دمويه في العالم كما لا
يعرف عنه سوى القليل باستثناء العمليات
التي نفذها في افريقيا ومعسكرته التدريبيه
وصلته بمقتل الصحفي الامريكي دانيال بيرل
في باكستان عام 2002 حسب ما اكده محققون
امريكيون بلال الوجداني العربيه